the hack that I found out about is all
you need are wine corks so if you keep
them handy after you polish off a bottle
it turns out apparently that wine corks
are a natural deterrent because the cork
material absorbs absorbs the moisture
that ripened fruits produce and when the
carbs quarks absorb the moisture it
gives off an odor that fruit flies hate
apparently yeah you can put them in and
sort of like tuck them in under the
fruits just you know stick them in the
crevices or underneath or at the bottom
of the bowl Now Zoe what is your hack
um you just put a little
um you get a a jar or a glass you put
some apple cider vinegar in and a few
drops of dish soap and they are
attracted to the vinegar and they die
[Laughter]